hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm asking the
question from one of my readers Jamie
who sent me a message from YouTube so
YouTube theater love my YouTube breeders
thank you long message so I'll try to
kind of cut it down but it's about
finding your passion so Jaime Ruadh
insane hi Evan thank you for creating
your videos I appreciate advice they
keep returning the same dilemma I've
watched video recently where you explain
a technique to list your passions things
you'd like to learn how much it's going
to help people and I'm stuck between
either being a businessman or music
artists and kind of skipping down what
do you think the risk point 10 to 20
years and become a musician that might
not make it or do I pour myself into
rewarding life in business that's when
the last three years going between
business and music and realize that need
to choose one of the other perhaps a
strange want to answer it's a strange
one to ask too thanks hope you're having
a good evening yours Jamie so great
question Jamie and finding your passion
and building a business around it is one
of the most important steps you have to
do when you're launching the company too
many people try to start a business
because it just rying to make a lot of
money and rarely do you see those
companies work out because it's hard
it's really tough and if you look at the
most successful entrepreneurs in the
world you'll find that they created
their business because they really had a
strong passion for it and they love what
they do they would do it even if they
weren't getting paid and it would find
another way to make money so you want to
be able to find that passion put it into
your business so that when it does
really get hard you're able to keep
plowing through all the barriers they're
going to come out to shape come at you
and keep going into the future in terms
of what to do into the business or music
I would try to find a way to combine
them and in one of the books that I'm a
big fan of called built to last it looks
at combining the genius of the end and
that's where you see a lot of mediocre
companies say we're either going to do
this or this but the best companies and
the companies that stay around and stick
and last for years and years are the
ones who say we're going to do this and
this and they look at ideas that are
most people would think don't go well
together and they find a way to match
them and I think I thought can apply
well to your business somewhere here
talked about some of your passions on
the business side is technology
programming business efficiency if you
look at most musicians and I deal with a
lot of them from being in the salsa
world there's a lot of salsa bands that
come in for the most part musicians are
awesome in what they do but they're not
great on the business side and they're
not great with technology and they're
definitely not great with programming
now there are a few that can will break
the mold but in general artists are not
great at the business side and it's it's
too bad because a lot of artists have a
hard time promoting themselves and being
good business owners so if you have that
ability to combine the two it's a very
powerful combination that I wouldn't
want you to feel like you have to give
up one of the other you know if you're a
musician you can only probably go so far
as a musician if you're a programmer you
can go so far as a program if you can
combine them you could be one of the
best in the world at those two things
together and there's going to be other
people who can learn from you and
benefit from you so an example you know
if say a lot of the the bands aren't
great business people how can you
combine your skill with music and
understanding of that plus your skill on
the business side and programming
technology to make them a lot better add
a lot more value and also tap into both
of your passions at the same time and I
try to look for ways to combine your
skills because that makes you really
unique you know if I want and try to
find a programmer just tons of
programmers out there right and are you
going to be the best programmer in the
world maybe but probably not you know
you're the best at you you're the best
of what you can do and so the more you
can tie in Europe your passions of
personal interests together into that
unique package the more value you're
going to be able to bring the right kind
of client and the goal here to be a
successful entrepreneur is not to be
able to target everybody but to target a
niche where you can be the best in the
world at what you do and that's how you
can make a lot of money but also add a
lot of value to your community and make
it really fulfilling and personally
rewarding so as much you can combine
those the better and I don't know what
the magic answer is but you're basically
looking for ways that you can find you
can add value to your clients and
combine those specific interests so it
could be around the musicians it could
be on the programming side but ideally
you can combine both of those together
to make a successful business
out of that answered your question or
gave you more confusion but it again you
could tie into what's uniquely you and
build a business around that then you
have a long-term sustainable competitive
advantage over your customers you can
charge more you'll get a lot more
satisfaction out of your life and you
don't you won't feel like you're always
forced to pick between one or the other
so hopefully that helps for those are
you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more videos for you
and you have a comment about this video
or if you have a question about your own
struggle or business I'd love to hear
from you I'd love to try to help out if
you wanna leave in the comment section
below I always read those so thank you
and I'll see you on the next episode
you